nick cannon about to welcome baby number
eight any minute we could be having this
baby so he knows he's on call and only
e.t is sitting down with model breatzy
about their unconventional relationship
even if we weren't physically we will
always be together
how chris pratt's nine-year-old son is
handling big brother duty he's so sweet
with them and they love him so much
and another e.t exclusive kevin costner
on yellowstone's future
no i don't know would you want to know
yeah
i'm going to end it if it doesn't end
i'll go till i'm not interested et's the
download starts right now
we start with proud papa nick cannon he
has seven children from four different
women and baby number eight is on the
way only et's kevin frazier sat down
with mama to be british to talk
motherhood and how she and nick plan to
move forward as a modern family
legendary love yes i think this just you
know plays into our relationship how are
you feeling i'm feeling great yeah
excited i'm so excited um nervous of
course yeah this could happen any moment
i mean it could happen during this
interview
[Music]
brie who was due any second confirmed
the pregnancy in january after was
leaked to the press the news came less
than two months after the tragic passing
of nick and alyssa scott's
five-month-old son zen some people gave
you grief about that announcement how
hard was that our plan was actually to
keep this private until it was
it wasn't such a sensitive time my heart
goes out to her so that was the last
thing i wanted to do
um was hit her while she was down and
him you know they're both grieving so it
was it was tough uh do you ever
communicate with any of the other ladies
no i respect everyone's you know space
at some point we will we just don't
necessarily need to at the moment i
think no matter what the kids are going
to be super close brae and nick have
been dating off and on for nearly a
decade they first met on the set of
nick's game show while in out
brie actually left nick in 2017 and
married football star johnny manziel so
i think that's probably the most
interesting part is that
at
any moment that i say i'm unhappy or
maybe you know what maybe this isn't for
me i did reconsider it at some point and
i did get married and then i knew that
really wasn't for me how did he take
that he was like okay i'll be here when
you get back
could you ever see you two being
together permanently
i mean i plan on being together
permanently no matter what even if we
weren't physically we will always be
together we will always maintain our
relationship as for where i would go
from that i don't know
you know it's 2022 and
anything goes you know what big families
are the vibe okay goodbye speaking of
big families another member of the
kardashian jenner family is back on the
market this news tops tonight's kiss and
tell after two years together kendall
jenner and nba star devin booker have
called it quits but all hope is not lost
a source tells e.t they could get back
together but right now kendall feels
like they're on different paths the pair
have been relatively tight-lipped about
their love life since they were first
linked in june of 2020 but she always
showed support courtside i watch every
game unless i have last night i had a
dinner but all my friends and family
know that i like sit with my phone
wherever i am and just last month they
were spotted together in italy for her
sister courtney's wedding with travis
barker now another notoriously private
couple is going strong and packing on
the pda taylor swift and joe alwyn were
spotted lock and lips in the bahamas
this amid engagement rumors
[Music]
now taylor didn't reveal anything about
the romantic rendezvous on social media
she wasn't posting all the pics but she
did let fans know her new single
carolina drops tonight it'll be featured
in the upcoming thriller where the
crawdads sang fans got a taste of the
track in the trailer
[Music]
britney spears and sam escari are
skipping the tropical vacation for now
but it looks like they are settling into
their new 12 million dollar home two
weeks after their star-studded wedding
yep this is the one in the same
neighborhood as her ex kevin fetterline
britt shared new pics of the backyard on
instagram writing it's so weird i wake
up and everything is new new pool new
kitchen new bed i think i'm in shock but
she seems to be enjoying all her recent
milestones adding life is good and it's
looking pretty good for benefer too j-lo
was spotted back on the set of ben's new
nike drama this week the pair looking
super cozy during some down time on the
lot now from ben's new project to
wedding planning the power couple is of
course keeping busy but they're still
very dedicated to each other and their
families this according to an et source
and here's the proof just a couple of
days ago jlo shared this snippet of ben
and her 14 year old child emmy begging
for a cat mom i will take the best care
of this cat like i don't think you
understand you hear that sincerely it's
time for you to open your hearts to a
cat again you can do they leave
give them the cat
right all right another couple we love
chris pratt and catherine schwarzenegger
the jurassic world dominion star turned
43 this week and he told us his wife
gave him the day off
i got a hall pass to go golf which was
pretty fun and then i had a very low-key
day spent it with my daughters and my
wife and i cooked some steaks at home
and it was pretty fun you know chris's
family is growing fast his second
daughter eloise was born just last month
and his nine-year-old son with his ex
anna ferris is loving it he does a great
job as a big brother he's so sweet with
them and
they love him so much and they miss him
when he's gone
you can see chris next in the terminal
list on prime video july 1st where he
plays a navy seal and a mission gone
wrong
i'm not gonna tell you again
stay off my list get this chris is an
executive producer on the series which
also stars his brother-in-law patrick
schwarzenegger
as a boss he's a yeah now he's a 10 10
boss 10 father 10
uh friend 10 brother-in-law everything
i've got a very understanding and loving
wife who who stepped up and and and took
care of took care of business at home
while i was basically
leaving before she woke up and and
getting home after she'd gone to bed
all right let's talk movies euphoria
star hunter schaefer is joining the cast
of the hunger games they broke the news
on the franchise's official instagram
page announcing hunter will play tigress
snow in the ballad of song birds and
snakes it's the prequel to the original
hunger games trilogy and the fifth film
in the series the movie comes out
november of next year
it's been
like
an enormous blessing it's completely
turned my world upside down it's been
like such a good space to be able to
like explore myself like as an artist
and here is another reason to get
excited about the upcoming barbie movie
margot robbie and ryan gosling as cowboy
ken and barbie now margot plays the
iconic doll whose life in plastic is
fantastic and ryan is reportedly one of
several kens so there's gonna be some
drama in that dream house you know this
is the first photo we've seen of the two
characters together and we gotta say
they completely nailed to the last
compared to western ken and barbie from
back in the day especially ryan's
longtime love eva mendes is also into
his transformation just like us posting
though that's my can
and get ready to shout oppa
because my big fat greek wedding three
has started filming in greece nia
vardalos confirmed the rumor on
instagram and made a major announcement
thank you so much uh for the lovely
messages of just waiting and everything
um i'm in a little room getting ready to
go down and film oh i want to teach you
your first greek word which is
uh
and what that means is um
director and guess who the director is
it's me
it's been exactly 20 years since the
first movie debuted and made mia a star
but moving on now to bridgeton alum
reggae jean page will the duke of
hastings make a return to the wildly
popular series when one burns for
someone who does not feel the same
sadly the answer is no i'm sorry i got
tripped up seeing that [ __ ]
the actor is once again shooting down
recent rumors sparked by this pick
showing him with co-star jonathan bailey
at fashion week in milan after reggie's
departure in 2021 creator shonda rhimes
offered fans this alternative
the duke is never gone he's always
available on netflix to be binge watched
over and over and over and over more
bridgeton scoop season three is on the
way in may we learned it'll focus on
colin and penelope's love story a
prediction et's lauren zima actually
made in march is it
a story of penelope and colin
i don't know
i said i just got hot i just got hot
okay so colin for season three
what
meanwhile real life royals prince
william and kate middleton reacted today
to their first official joint portrait
the royals looking regal and that's a
real life look from kate she wore the
same emerald dress to a guinness factory
in dublin two years ago the artist says
in a statement he wanted to have the
couple look relaxed and approachable as
well as elegant and dignified it'll
remain on display at the fitzwilliam
museum at the university of cambridge
for the next three years all right now
to american royalty all right things are
heating up for khloe kardashian in
today's talk show circuit on a new
episode of hot ones she revealed her
secrets for escaping paparazzi
my sisters and i did wear prosthetics we
went on like a tmz type tour bus oh no
one knew who we were at first and then
they started figuring out our act we
like spoken accents for some reason and
we weren't solid
that stunt like much of the kardashians
lives was featured on keeping up back in
2016. paparazzi doesn't realize it's
kendall kylie and i all right everybody
welcome aboard kim kardashian's favorite
place over there loves to get the
chinese chicken kardashians the
kardashians
gloria estefan also got spicy on watch
what happens live when she reacted to
this moment from jlo's halftime
documentary
this is the worst idea in the world to
have two people do the super bowl i
think they wanted to throw a miami and
latin extravaganza right and they they
try to put any pack in as much as
possible and they killed it but you were
asked to perform okay imagine what jayla
would have said if i would have been a
third which i literally would have come
out come and check your body out right
look it's their moment they're in a
whole other thing i've done a couple of
super bowls
i didn't want to go on a diet in
december
queen gloria has performed at three
super bowls in 1992 1995 and 1999. she
holds a record for the most performances
alongside justin timberlake and ichi was
actually there as she trained like an
athlete for her very first appearance i
have to maintain a really rigorous
exercise schedule so i've been working
out very hard probably about two and a
half hours a day and speaking of records
tom hanks may hold one for crashing the
most weddings he does it so well why
well here's what he told seth meyers
it's my ego unchecked i just can't help
but think what would these people like
more than anything else to remember this
magic day of days
oh i know
me
i actually caught up with one happy
couple last october who were shocked
when hanks strolled up to their
beachside nuptials he did say that he
noticed our ceremony and he said i had
to stop it was such a beautiful ceremony
um i noticed you two from afar
and
i mean
it was crazy i don't know right you go
for a jog and then hey let me stop and
crash his wedding
well speaking of tom hanks his newest
movie elvis hits theaters tomorrow star
uh austin butler told et's michelle
turner what it took to become the king
the hardest part of channeling him is it
the lip curl is it the hip like what
what is it there's so many things out
there that have become these caricatures
and so even talking about him curling
his lip it's something he didn't do as
much as we think he did right or he'd do
it for a photo and so he was finding how
subtle could you go with things and
still have the essence
[Music]
and i had our exclusive one-on-one
inside elvis gold record room at
graceland and you know i had to ask why
is it that 15 months after shooting
wrapped he still has that elvis accent
there's a lot of people saying a lot of
things i would be remiss internet if i
didn't say yes we still hear it in your
voice and the internet's losing its mind
because of that do can you just not
shake them you just can't shake you know
at this point i keep asking people is
this my voice i don't know when you live
with something for two years and you do
nothing else i think you can't help but
it becomes a fiber of your being you
know well hello there
hi
i'm lucas's cousin derek oh yes you are
yeah that's what a 16 year old austin
sounded like in 2007 alongside miley
cyrus in hannah montana but he's come a
long way in fact austin actually sang
all the elvis songs himself check out
this early screen test
well that's all right mama
that's all right for you like where have
you been all of our lives sounding like
that yeah so i i used to only ever sing
for people very close to me because i i
didn't believe it in the beginning but i
wanted to i wanted to take on the
challenge right
grab him
your mano imano with one of the greatest
actors
of all time then tom hanks when i first
met him he goes my boy and he holds out
his arms and gives me the biggest bear
hug he's as advertised isn't he yeah
he's everything you imagine him to be
you hear him laugh down the hallway and
you go that's woody
[Laughter]
now to another megastar from memphis
justin timberlake the poor guy just
wants to tell you he is sorry for what
something is an extremely whack dance
performance so this video is making the
social media rounds with jt looking like
a dad chaperoning his kid's party and
now he just wants to show you he's still
got it but the 41 year old learned the
hard way that his sexy maybe isn't back
in this case i want to apologize to you
for two reasons here and here maybe it
was the khakis this is a real khaki vibe
i'm gonna make this up to you
i'm gonna focus
on these two guys right here
he will be in good company because
twitter is undefeated and very focused
on his dancing disaster at pharrell's
something in the water festival one that
stands out i wonder if janet and
brittany ever text each other another
funny tweet did justin timberlake just
get off work because the alpha is very
much i.t specialist i think his shoes
are from zara it was definitely a
celebrities are just like us kind of
moment and jt did not just say beat your
feet and proceed to river dance and skip
boy if you don't get your ass off the
stage i am dying reading me listen this
is all in good fun of course okay
because jt's got plenty to keep him busy
his son silas and phineas and his wife
jessica biel just shared some rare
photos of them and right now they're
enjoying some time together at paris
fashion week they'll celebrate their
10th anniversary for their wedding in
october that once you find that person
there's like a baptism where you're like
i can't go back
you know what i mean like i don't i
can't go back so which is what
fatherhood's like too so i'm just
enjoying the ride someone else who's
faced trolls head-on erica jane i sat
down with the real housewives of beverly
hills star whose legal woes have played
out in the public eye
obviously last season horrible
just let's just call it what it was
horrible i mean there was a lot of
attention on you this is a lot of
cases wrapped up in one and it's going
to take a very long time to sort all of
this out
i'm fighting literally for my life
to recap the 50 year old has been named
in several lawsuits alongside her
estranged husband tom girardi he's
accused of a multi-million dollar
embezzlement scandal used to fuel her
lavish lifestyle in 2020 she filed for
divorce a month before he filed for
bankruptcy
how do you feel having to constantly
defend your actions it's tiring you know
but i do work and i get paid and so
there we have it and again i'm in a long
nasty legal battle
so what's next for erica the slate has
been wiped clean in the sense of the
life that i had has been burned to the
ground
so i really get to rebuild from ground
zero i'm having a good time i'm
doing new ventures like pretty mess hair
i'm still on reality television just was
in the studio a few days ago i want to
return to the stage i really honestly am
at this place in my life i could do
anything at once
[Music]
lucky for fans of erica she told me she
is back in the studio so we're gonna get
some new music from miss erica jane soon
i still ahead the winner of the
westminster dock show trumpet the
bloodhound reveals his cheat meal to e.t
and my exclusive sit down with john
dutton himself kevin costner on what
would make him quit yellowstone right
now we have our foot on the gas and that
feels okay
to me
et's the download we'll be right back
[Music]
brad pitt is revealing he spent a year
searching for buried treasure in the
august issue of gq out july 17th he
explains that a few years ago someone
told him there was millions in gold
buried at his chateau miraval winery in
france so he started digging and digging
and digging some more but found nothing
the actor says he felt foolish in the
end you guys this is a real story but he
did enjoy the adventure and adventure is
what he gave us in the oceans trilogy
if any of you try to screw me
you'll be dead
well when you cross one ocean you face
them all in this case 13 of them he hurt
ruben i know what that makes me want to
do i'll get him leaving his barber then
i'll inject them and i'll find a spot to
get rid of the body all valid ideas but
this time the fellas go after al pacino
a casino mogul who swindles one of danny
ocean's associates to finance his new
vegas hotel i got the hottest new hotel
on the strip
okay then while the entire mail cast
reprised the roles julia roberts did not
return catherine zeta jones who appeared
in ocean's 12th was also noticeably
missing instead ellen barkin joined the
cast they're so close in life and they
have such an enormous respect and
admiration for each other you just feel
it it's like palpable
there are a couple of characters here
i'm not too sure about now if you ever
wondered what it's like to hang with the
ocean's crew
i need to go to sleep though at night
that's the they don't sleep well you
know first of all they're boys oh
they're all so exhausting the
interesting thing about this movie was
that there were a bunch of new babies
casey had babies eddie brad me and yet
george wore more diapers than any of the
kids
in 2007 the film took the boys from can
to hollywood where matt damon brad pitt
and george clooney were all cemented
into history you are now immortalized in
hollywood yes that's it i'm now i've
been in cement now a little squishy i
used to do construction work it's a
little nicer when they do it for you
here
well now two more hollywood legends
kevin costner and sylvester stallone i
sat down with the two in literally the
best day of my life while in london she
celebrates the launch of paramount plus
in the uk
you know taylor has actually told me
that he knows how yellowstone ends do
you know
no i don't know how it ends would you
want to know yeah
i'm going to end it if it doesn't end
how long do you
i don't know but i'll go tell i'm not
interested right now we have our foot on
the gas and that feels okay
to me
beth what the hell you doing now there's
a lot of emmys buzz surrounding the show
what would that recognition mean to you
the idea that it's good
that doesn't surprise me at all the idea
that it blew up that's something you
can't always predict heading into season
five kevin and the cast are riding high
not only are there 14 episodes instead
of 10 kohlhauser who plays rip says the
first two episodes are fantastic one
cliffhanger from the end of season four
the relationship between kevin's john
dutton and his adopted son what would
you want to see happen with jamie could
you see him
falling in good graces with john again
probably the show would end
you know there'd be nothing to play
against i don't like drama in my own
life personally i don't like it you know
some people seem to thrive on drama i
don't really like it so my dysfunctional
family really disturbs me
i can walk away from it yellowstone
returns november 13th on the paramount
network also premiering that day another
new show from taylor sheridan tulsa king
starring sylvester stallone sly plays a
mobster who after getting out of prison
gets sent to tulsa oklahoma
tulsa i want you to go there this is a
joke well i've always wanted to play a
gangster but it never happened better
late than never could we see you maybe
pop up in any of his other projects
because i feel like yellowstone could
use a gangster to shake up some things
with the duttons
i like the way you roll i've known kevin
for like centuries too that'd be great
good man
you know fans really want to see it
happen my social media is blowing up
with fans like all four of those i see
it yeah let's make it happen all right
well those men are total winners so is
trumpet that's right last night he
became the first bloodhound ever to
stack best in show at the westminster
dog show and his owner seems to think
the sky's the limit he's four and a half
so he's in his prime but he just started
showing in january so we we've decided
to just keep going and see what he can
do the rest of the year congratulations
trumpet
all right take a look at trumpet taren
up this silver platter of steak get this
y'all that is his favorite cheat meal
after he wins big trumpet save now he'd
be out winston a french bulldog owned by
l.a chargers player morgan fox and
winston a chow chow related to one of
martha stewart's past who won best in
breed
i cannot keep up with this
i can't get over the steak cheat meal
that's so good well that's going to do
it for us today
i love the puppies okay catch us
tomorrow for another episode of eating
the download goodbye
[Music]